sie haben die kanzlerin erlebt als
parteichefin eben natürlich als
bundeskanzlerin aber gab es einen moment
bei denen sie heute sagen würden da habe
ich sie ganz besonders als mensch erlebt
ja vielleicht ganz am anfang im jahr
2000 als sie in essen
nachfolgerin von schäuble geworden ist
als parteivorsitzende da hat sie das war
eine sehr starker
emotionaler moment den man ja bei ihr
sehr selten erlebt hat und es war dann
auch eine erlebnisse ich habe mir dann
so in alter manier boxhandschuhe
schenken wollen und wollte zum kampf
jetzt und hat sie natürlich die box an
ja die hat sie natürlich entgegen
genommen aber sie hat mir schon zu
erkennen gegeben dass sie also die
politik nicht unbedingt mit
boxhandschuhen machen möchte sondern was
sich ja dann durch ihre ganze amtszeit
durchzieht sie war immer sehr sehr stark
auf konsens ausgerichteten einzubinden
lange abzuwarten bis man möglichkeit
jetzt eines konsenses findet also so
musste sich daneben und stoiber auch
erstmal in diesen anderen stil gewöhnen
von angela merkel wir haben uns ja dann
bildet sie in diesen tagen ein bisschen
menschlich gesehen zu haben die angela
merkel nämlich beim großen zapfenstreich
den sie auch verfolgt haben herr stoiber
als es diesen moment gehabt mit der rose
wir haben sie diesen moment beim
zapfenstreich erlebt er stoiber sie war
so wie sie immer ist sehr zurückhaltend
nicht sehr stark emotional wenn man
vergleicht nun mal vergleicht ihren
vorgänger gerhard schröder der tränen in
den augen hat auch natürlich helmut kohl
das ist
bei ihr nicht zu erwarten weil sie
alles rational macht und relativ wenig
emotional es zulässt das was sie gerade
hier im bild zeigen das ist ein
wunderbares bild das ist auch ein
emotionales bild und das gefällt mir
außerordentlich in das gehört auch zu
angela merkel
aber sie ist natürlich sie hat einen
anderen stil in die politik gebracht
sehr rational sehr fakten orientiert
sich selbst nicht in den vordergrund
stellen das team die sache
unprätentiös das geht mit ihr absolut
nach hause und da hat da ist sie
stilbildend aber es kommen auch andere
im moment es gibt natürlich momente wo
sie ganz anders war als man sie
eingesetzt hat fukushima der schnelle
ausstieg aus der kernenergie obwohl man
ein paar wochen vorher noch länger die
kernenergie
prognostiziert hat für deutschland
natürlich auch der große streitpunkt
will ich nicht die ausklammern die
flüchtlingskrise das ist etwas was
prägend auch für diese kanzlerschaft war
und das auch bleiben wird weil die
herausforderung die stehen ja weiter vor
uns wir haben ja leider
da es nicht geschafft eine europäische
lösung gäbe es ohne angela merkel heute
überhaupt die afg also das glaube ich
dass kann man nicht sicher sagen aber
natürlich hat die flüchtlingskrise
hat natürlich hat natürlich deutschland
gespalten aber es hat auch europa
gespalten und ich meine man muss ganz
fair sagen boris johnson hätte dem bag
sieht nie erreicht ohne die bilder im
deutschen fernsehen hier in england
gezeigt hat in seinen
wahlkampfauftritten wo eben
hunderttausende über die grenze über die
ostgrenze über ungarn und natürlich über
österreich nach deutschland gekommen
sind und er hat natürlich das hat
natürlich
kultur unterschiede aufgezeigt
westeuropa dann sieht dass ein stück
anders als osteuropa nordeuropa wieder
anders als südeuropa und wir haben hier
eine echte spaltung wir haben alle
versuche eine europäische lösung zu
finden nicht erreicht die überwiegende
mehrheit der deutschen mag bis heute
angela merkel schätzt sie als kanzlerin
würden sie sagen es gibt etwas an ihr
was sowas ist wie typisch deutsch
ja typisch deutsch
die sache steht die wahlen
sie
entspricht natürlich der großen
mentalität der deutschen
die person in einer zeit wo so viel über
mich geredet wird die person nicht in
den vordergrund rücken also vergleichen
sie mal man kann vergleichen sie mal das
pathos von makro dazu natürlich der
französischen geschichte geschuldet ist
und wie das bei den franzosen mehr oder
wenn er ankommt stellen sie sich mal vor
angela merkel ist gerade das gegenteil
hängt natürlich auch mit unserer
geschichte zusammen und sie war gerade
in dienen und in der sachlichkeit und in
der geringen selbstdarstellung was ja
wirklich außergewöhnlich ist der sucht
sich selbst darzustellen
hat merkel nie gehabt und dienen war
sozusagen ihr entscheidendes wort der
sache dienen dem land dienen man kann
sich angela merkel vorstellen dass sie
in den nächsten supermarkt geht und das
abendbrot einkauft das hat man ja auch
hin und wieder gesehen da sagen die
leute heute mehrheitlich ja so ist sie
man hat ihr das zugetraut dass sie jetzt
schnell vom kanzleramt drüber geht und
und zur rede oder wo auch immer und
schnell was einkauft und wieder nach
hause gehen die kanzler geht bei jedem
anderen muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen
dass ich nehmen sie mal schöner hier
stelle ich mir vor schröder wäre also
jetzt in den supermarkt gegangen und
hätte sich die bockwurst gekaufte was da
hätte man sofort gesagt ja das macht er
jetzt nur weil ich meine dass gar nicht
kritisch war merkel ist das nie
aufgekommen sondern so ist sie und das
geht mit ihr nach hause und das ist wohl
auch die die die die die grundlage ihrer
großen popularität bei den deutschen
denn das erwarten vielleicht die
deutschen gar nicht so unbedingt von
politiker aber sie freund aber natürlich
sind sie ja sehr angetan wenn jemand
sich so in einer solchen aufgabe
so darstellt wie er selber eigentlich
auch machen würden wohl sortiert man
angela merkel jetzt am ende eigentlich
ein war sie eine große kanzlerin für sie
und wenn wir die ganze kanzler galerie
einmal ablaufen da haben kanzleramt wo
gehört sie dahin vor einen helmut kohl
vor einen konrad adenauer oder sozusagen
nur vor ein gerhard schröder
die haben kann dass das wird sich
ehrlicherweise kann man das heute nicht
sagen natürlich wissen wir heute
der gründungs kanzler adenauer hat diese
junge republik stabilisiert und sie in
den kreis der welt geführt natürlich
kann man sagen willy brandt hat die ost
politik völlig verändert und neue
perspektiven geschaffen natürlich wird
man mit helmut kohl sagen kanzler der
einheit kanzler europas
angela merkel hat eine eigene note das
ist die länge der amtszeit das in die
krisen mit denen über die wir gerade
gesprochen haben ich würde mal sagen sie
läuft schon unter krisen kanzler oder
krisenkanzlerin sie hat die krise
jedenfalls so abgefedert dass die
deutschen gut durch diese krisen
vielleicht jetzt mit ausnahme der korona
krise die wir noch nicht bewältigt haben
gekommen sind und das spüren die
menschen dass sie gut durch diese
herausforderung ich habe die krisen
genannt eurokrise finanzkrise und und
flüchtlingskrise hier sind haben nicht
alles gelöst aber wir sind gut
durchgekommen und es ist ja letztens
auch ihr wort in der flüchtlingskrise
das deutlich macht
2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen
das sagt die frau die sagt wir schaffen
das damit hat sie ist sie auch auf die
kritiker letzten endes eingegangen hat
auch hier wieder den konsens gesucht ob
der trägt bei einer erneuten krise
werden das ja bloß sehen
herzlichen dank für das spannende
gespräche edmund stoiber der langjährige
bayerische ministerpräsident danke chef
und der politische mitstreiter und
zeitweise auch konkurrenz von angela
merkel dankte herzlich für das gespräch